when humans touched down in a new planet
we're going to need some help making it
more homey bring a robot or two for the
grunt work but maybe think twice about
bots that look like us most of them have
a real hard time just walking around
what humans really need is task oriented
robots like NASA's bigger prototype this
tank track little guy is built to mine
the surface of Mars with backhoe claws
that spin in opposite direction so the
robot doesn't flip over while this guy
digs for water and minerals on Mars
humans will be free to do the fine-motor
stuff that we're so good at but to get
around we'll need new space studs like
NASA's prototype z2 suit which has
flexible joints designed for exoplanets
strolling not spacewalks it's bubble
helmet visor will make it easier to see
what you're working on oh and to avoid
stepping all over our robot friends easy
little guy